i'm here with assistant professor of
computer science to launch on vanner G
of the University of Maryland at
Baltimore County and senior research
program manager Arjumand samuel of
Microsoft Research they're going to tell
us about some exciting research into
improving the quality of life for
paralysis patients thanks for being here
guys appreciate it this is gonna be fun
we'll start with you nilanjana near a
professor of computer science you're not
a medical doctor or a physical therapist
we're sort of wondering how you came to
be involved in working with paralysis so
it all started with usability study that
we did at Madonna rehabilitation
hospital in Nebraska so I have a
collaborator there who is actually a
medical doctor so in that usability
study we were trying to figure out what
are the limitations of assistive devices
and what we found was most of the
devices that people use nowadays
especially people the paralysis for
environmental control is very bulky as
well as very expensive so we thought we
need to do something about this problem
so so we worked with these doctors at
Madonna trying to actually build systems
which can be embedded into your items of
daily use okay this could be like
clothing this could be bad sheets pillow
covers and so on and so forth and it can
detect gestures for people with
paralysis for environmental control okay
so let's let's dive deeper into that so
as a computer scientist how are you
working to improve the quality of life
for these patients so I'm basically
building sensors in collaboration with
Microsoft Research which can detect very
subtle gestures of patients suffering
with paralysis so they can use these
sensors for controlling appliances
making a nurse call or even making a 911
call so on the systems that I'm building
would be kind of invisible from the
patients so embedded in surroundings
around them and they would kind of work
seamlessly with minimal intrusiveness so
is this similar to when quadriplegic
used you know the head sticks or the
lasers to control switches or keyboards
it is similar but it's much less
intrusive right so essentially these
answers are kind of invisible from the
patient so and does the same same task
as laser mounted headgears so obviously
this work must be you know difficult but
incredibly rewarding talk about some of
the things you've already witnessed
happening here right so one of our team
members is actually a patient who
suffers from paralysis his name is Buzz
and he has been using our system and
providing us feedback on how the system
could be improved for better usability
of patients of that group so I think the
biggest reward for us here is when Buzz
actually uses the system to control his
appliances at home mer seen him do it
here so just swiping his arm over his
knee was actually activating yes
anything from what TVs took two
appliances the lights yeah in that
particular demonstration he was actually
activating a lamp Wow and so talk about
how that it's obviously not just as
simple as that how do things like facial
gestures in waving of the arm translate
into to activating something that's
across the room or maybe across the
house right so essentially our sensors
are capacitive sensors so they act as
proximity sensors but they can be built
into clothing so what these proximity
sensors do is you've got one in front of
you here that's correct so these this is
one preliminary prototype that we have
developed and the sensors are actually
embedded inside the jeans fabric or the
denim fabric and the idea here is to use
these sensors as as proximity sensors so
anybody waving their hand on top of
these sensors would be detected as a
gesture and over a Bluetooth connection
to a computer it can be used for
controlling different apply so that's
how the date is process and then it's
sent on to the things that are being
controlled that's correct wow that is
fascinating so this is a good
opportunity to bring you into the
conversation Armand walk us through the
components of the lab of things and sort
of explain how they facilitate research
like what's happening with Milan John
right so the lab of things is a research
platform for the Internet of Things now
the vision of the Internet of Things is
that the common things around
would become smarter and as we like to
call it ambient computing would be all
around us so things would just be
smarter and they would be thinking so if
a researcher like nilanjan would be
developing such sensors or things the
lab of things makes it easier for them
to deploy and do to do research in that
space now of course the lab of things
opens up this researcher opportunity for
the Internet of Things and we are just
starting to see some of the cool
scenarios that can be enabled by yeah
and this one is certainly one of those
in as you mentioned on John's work isn't
the only current research that is using
lab of things I understand it's also
being used to study electrical usage in
homes what can you tell us about some of
that research right so since the level
thing is really a platform which really
brings down the barrier to research in
this new space we are seeing level
things today being used in energy
management is one domain research domain
where people are looking at how to
optimize place energy usage in places in
countries where there is less energy
there's one then we are also looking at
its applications in health care this one
sensor is one but more so in other parts
of healthcare like in place aging when
people is at home we want to augment
their environments with with technology
talk about that right that's so
increasingly we are seeing that of
course people are getting older Taylor
longer and they live they want to live
at home sure comparatively healthier
lives where they can move around but
still they we would want and the
caregivers would want to know how
they're living and would want constant
feedback and would know want to know if
they fall while sleeping or so all of
those things can be detected with
sensors but of course we have to figure
out what are the right kinds of sensors
to put in these environments and also
what are the issues of privacy security
reliability that need to be built into
these infrastructure right and all of
that is only possible if we do some
research into that space and try to
figure out what are the right system
design so the lab of things enables all
of that so it is a platform it's an open
platform which allows people to exercise
the creativity in different research
domains are there any other ongoing lab
of things projects that you can tell us
about yeah there are quite a number
quite a few of
so of course this is one then we have
one in Pakistan where they're looking at
energy use in that country because
chronically there is a shortage of power
electrical power there and they want to
optimize how power is to be used to the
home and how they can switch on and off
different appliances then we have people
who are looking at the lab of things and
connecting it to the Kinect sensor and
trying to figure out if people suffering
with Parkinson's disease how are they
doing when they walk in the morning are
they getting better or worse and to give
their caregiver some kind of notice that
this this person is not feeling well so
that's another project that's happening
at Purdue University right now so so we
have quite a few of those projects and
our site has a more exhaustive list
there yeah and obviously you've got a
lot of folks interested someone here in
our online audience already sent in a
question 2 yards month is how do I get
started using the lab of things platform
lab off things calm that's where you go
to the site we have downloadable source
code all of our source is is there you
can download it and start playing with
it now another feature of the lab of
things which we started off earlier on
is that it's a community-based
infrastructure so vile v-max of research
has provided this platform but the
drivers and the applications that run on
the platform are being contributed by
the community by researchers like
nilanjan and so if this person on the
online would like to contribute code
codeplex is the site where we host our
code they can then put it back into the
repository and then other researchers
can use it from there so it's truly a
community-based infrastructure which we
would like the community researching in
the Internet of Things domain to really
use in pretty impressive community in a
tremendous resource this is fantastic
trails yeah and we want to shift
back to your work and particular
knowledge on what are the next steps for
you and lab of things so this entire
platform right now is build on top of
lab of things so one of the things i
want to do with this particular sensor
is to make it commercially available in
the next two or three years so some of
the things that we are working on right
now is
mature izing this particular module so
this is pretty big and it's an initial
prototype insider' big register so we
want to actually make it really really
small so that they can be embedded into
your clothing and would be literally
invisible from you so that's one area
that we are working hard on I think that
the biggest reward for something like
this would be if this is commercially
available people can buy it and people
like buzz can actually use it to improve
their standard of living now we've got a
question for you from the online
audiences I recognize that motion
sensors currently can detect when
someone walks into a room wouldn't that
be the way in all an alternative way to
turn on a light and it says can you
elaborate on this and how it's more
beneficial so this is this provides a
much richer set of gestures than motion
sensing right so motion sensing like in
rooms can detect whether you're going
into the room or getting out of the room
but this can detect complex gestures the
swype is just one gesture that we used
for the demonstration out there it can
detect like writing alphabets it can
detect like a large set of gestures that
could be used for for appliance controls
of different types so the set of
gestures is much richer and also since
this is variable then potentially you
take the sensor with you and can be used
for control from anywhere literally and
so talk about the process of getting
this technology getting it to work
seeing it in action and then like you
said going back to the drawing board
saying great now we're gonna make it
smaller everybody rethink everything we
already did right is that is it
frustrating is it inspiring is it all of
the above no it's actually very
inspiring so initially when we started
this project you didn't really have any
paralysis patient on our team and we
were just building systems which work
but once we have buzz on the team we are
getting like explicit feedback on what
the sensor should look like where we
should place the sensors what would be
most comfortable and so on and so forth
and we are like improving the product
like almost every day now that's great
so I think it's very rewarding to learn
more from from patients in that domain
and junior technology that would be
useful for them just about our time he
one more question for you Irishmen what
future areas of research do you see
profiting from the use of lab of things
so there's a lot of things that still
can happen with the lab of things we
have hardly scratched the surface for
this big new world of the Internet of
Things privacy security reliability are
three big ones that need to be really
researched and understood before this
becomes a reality so in each of these
domains health care or energy management
all of these three privacy security and
reliability have told to play and we
need to understand that so in terms of
research that is where a lot of time
would be spent now in terms of the
infrastructure we are constantly talking
to collaborators our academic
collaborators and trying to figure out
what what is that they want what is that
would help them be more productive in
the research so that is an ongoing thing
and we are constantly iterating on a
design it's fascinating stuff nilanjana
irishman truly thank you it's been a
pleasure talking with you guys learning
about these rather exciting developments
with lab of things I'm betting our
viewers would like to know about lab of
things of cares so here's a short video
explains more about this exciting new
research platform let's see it the lab
of things by the very nature of this
design of the platform allows you to
innovate quickly it allows you to test
out a design it tests out your ideas
very quickly in real environments
collect data and then say if your design
is working or not working which is a
very big motivation for innovation we
are developing a textile based
capacitive sensors that could be built
into clothing bed sheets pillow covers
and even wheelchair pads so the idea
here is to use these sensors as
proximity sensors to detect gestures for
people with paralysis so people with
paralysis can use these gestures for
controlling the environment whether it's
lights switches televisions making a 911
call or even
making a nurse code lab of things
essentially provides the software
framework on top of which we have built
the data collection unit data processing
unit and gesture detection unit my hope
for this project is with this technology
to have folks that have injuries such
quadriplegics or other types of
impairments of there may be upper
extremities to be able to be more
independent to have a confidence that
they don't have to rely on someone all
the time this way they can live their
life as normal as possible and to be
able to just get out have fun and enjoy
life lab of things brings down the
barriers of doing research with
connected devices it brings down the
barriers by allowing people to deploy a
skill and deploying diverse geographies
and that is the power of the novelties
you